hey gang it's your old pals uncle hank
and kippy just want to thank you for
tuning in to ru garbage
yeah guys make sure you subscribe that
way you get the episode as they come out
you can also go to gasdigitalnetwork.com
use promo code ayg
to get bonus content and get the
episodes before they come out and hd
streaming
do it yeah welcome
to another exciting edition of are
you garbage the show where you find out
if your favorite comedians are classy
individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley oh baba
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast
this is r u gabbage the show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and find if they go classy
or if they're absolute trash i'm your
host dave foley coming at you on a
beautiful friday afternoon
here at gas digital studios he's lying
it's tuesday
prank call of duty power of television
take that zuckerberg i am your host
stage foley coming at you on a beautiful
day here at gas digital studios
my co-host is across the table from me
so you know it's a [ __ ] fan question
episode
just the family circle in the wagons no
gas no pressure
no [ __ ] no that it's just us gang
and we got a lot of your hot emails
couple of free range birds baby let's
they
can't keep me caged down daddy-o dang
do me a favor give me a nice big round
of applause for his [ __ ] macbook pro
kippy kevin james ryan hey what's up
gang thanks for uh tuning in everybody
love the family shows it's family style
get the eggplant parm out
the big bowl of pasta a little garlic
bread throw it in the middle of the
table
and let's have a little sunday evening
feast you know what i mean i don't know
i like this angle
the back that's really shown like i look
like i'm laying them down
you look like jabba the hutt on acid
eating that frog hey how was woodstock
well uh guys as always please make sure
you review subscribe on itunes
last i checked we were in the top 200
maybe fell out not sure man
but keep us in the top 200 guys it's the
[ __ ] we appreciate all the support so
much honestly it's [ __ ] amazing we
slid down that thing like a [ __ ]
booger on the wall
holy [ __ ] yeah we hung in there for
about a week we're hanging
we get in we get out we get a stick and
move we fly like a butt you know
you don't want to beat a rogan you don't
want to be joe rogan up there with the
bullseye on your back
you know what i mean say [ __ ] stick
and move get in get a couple more subs
get out you didn't get a couple
positions taking a little bit of a hit
um
but guys please please make sure you
subscribe on itunes and also full as you
know full video available on youtube uh
you can subscribe there as well we
appreciate all support uh thank you guys
and real quick since we're doing a
family show let's give credit where
credit's due
shout out to our amazing producer dylan
for all his hard work
hard work on the [ __ ] live show yeah
down there in philly
uh audio quality blame on him
but he's a good kid uh and the new
graphics and all that stuff he's [ __ ]
holding up the fort here
why uh why brian's uh not feeling well i
don't know if that's whatever
should i have said that i don't know
shut up just go on with the show you
[ __ ] i'm trying to [ __ ] give dylan
some props guys
this guy realized there's a camera on
him clams up real quick huh
by doing my hands like your mom on the
news
thank you thank you i saw the whole
thing guys
uh so as you know this is a listener
episode where you guys write in all your
questions we've
i mean we decided to do this like two
days ago we put the tweets out put the
post out
we've gotten [ __ ] hundreds hundreds
of questions
came in some even thousands some of you
are repeating
you know some of you what if some of you
might have never watched the show
because like have you ever [ __ ] your
mother
the dog what's up tell me a little rough
around the world the one thing i'm
finding
is people tweeting comics that we've
already had on the show
yeah you gotta have so and so we had a
[ __ ] two weeks ago yes guys so also
if you're not aware
the the the people that we've had on i
mean we've had bobby kelly paul versi
andrew schultz joe list mark norman
[ __ ] corrine fisher christina
hutchinson
i mean the who's who of [ __ ]
comedians and they're all available on
gas digital network only the most recent
15 episodes are available on youtube
for legal purposes for legal per passes
but you can use promo code ayg sign up
get those [ __ ] hit the bricks you
know what yeah
it's a good deal man it's a good deal
but we wouldn't steer you wrong we got
so many [ __ ] questions uh some of
them are [ __ ] home runs
home runs yeah on these that i'm like a
little jealous i didn't come up with
them
and some of them i've had sitting in the
hopper they came across from
these are good ones you know okay um
let's see but we've had we had multiple
come in
asking about us okay because
uh four inches if we're still an item
are you two still hot and heavy uh no
because
uh a lot of us don't just know us on the
show a little bit
we're off the show as guests so uh kind
of the a few people asked about the
origin of the podcast
and or us a little bit um so this is
from bobby who came up with the idea for
the podcast
that's funny you mention that let's get
this [ __ ] well documented
on audio because somebody was running
their mouth off uh before the other show
about some legal action that would be
taken by the ip
intellectual property i have retained
counsel that's already trademarked
under paddy foley uh patty fully
enterprises case something happens to me
all goes to my mom
yeah ma's getting the money she's got a
holding corp with uh
are you garbage and an above-ground pool
well the truth is
okay um how it came now listen
we're 50 50 no matter what okay kippy
and i
yes i do 90 of the work so if anyone's
counting out there there's not there's
nothing there's 50 50 ownership i do 90
of the heavy lifting there won't be any
legal battle it'll be like 50 50
we got a handshake deal yeah they got
the mcdonald's brothers
dumb [ __ ] what do you think i'm doing to
you i'm going to [ __ ] ray croc
this whole thing you think you're over
there selling hamburgers i'm buying real
estate
uh we've you know kevin and i have been
working together for years we started in
philadelphia together uh running shows
we don't need the whole
you know that's the raven lounge college
to play how many times i've heard this
[ __ ] story
every whatever i was it was a cold crisp
evening
we always kind of did it it was a game
we played we loved calling each other
but it wasn't defined as a game yeah but
we just did it to each other we would
ask each other questions about growing
up and be like oh that's [ __ ] trash
or garbage the first big one was milk
for dinner on the ride home from
when we were in altoon we did a road
show in altoona and without i remember
like dying we were like i was trashing
you for drinking milk for dinner yeah
and that was one that was like one of
the big first
you know and then we had done a podcast
called the center city comedy podcast
for many years with derek gaines with
derrick
tom cassidy we all started philly
together and then uh
one day i was in the shower and i said i
i thought of the actual
game like to play the game now it was
still undefined
at that moment and then we played it
once on that podcast with each other and
we [ __ ] loved it
and uh that's that's where it came from
and then kevin and i together
you know formed what this podcast is now
yeah and even before that we had another
podcast hard feelings yeah
so this is our third attempted uh
because somebody said did you have a
show
before ayg that bombed yeah we had two
of them
he goes i mean you guys have blown up
some of the biggest names in comedy have
been on the show thank you very much
was that a lucky shot or has it been
planned after a few things didn't work
out yeah yeah we kind of
meticulously plan i'll tell you that
part of it okay like when i say he's
always fine he's all foley
it's kippy you know kippy does the spo
and the [ __ ] algorithm or whatever
the [ __ ] it's called
spf 30. got the zinc on the nose
it's like a flannel um yeah but we've
thrown a couple things against the wall
learned you know retooled and you know
and now we're here and
we're so much we're so [ __ ] ecstatic
of all the support and everything yes
we love it like after the live show
there was a [ __ ] a bunch of people
hanging out taking pictures
the guy drove you here one crew drove
off from baltimore they got in the car
the kid hit a deer they turned around
and got a new car and [ __ ] drove they
totaled the car
what'd they do with the deer that's in
the trunk some jerky
couple venison steaks um yeah so
that's that's for the podcast a little
bit of background on the old uh kipster
and foley yeah but let's get into
some fan questions while we're [ __ ]
here
hit me this one i can't bring myself to
do
and it's a tough will you go out of your
way for a free donut free slurpee free
coffee on those national donut et cetera
days
that's from robert no you've never been
like oh it's free
no free crueler day let me [ __ ] swing
by never
no no why because one you're poor and
two you like a nice [ __ ] sugary snack
that's riff-raff [ __ ] it is that's
refresh
you can't spend the 79 cents to get to
yeah
day before rita's water ice is a famous
water ice place in philly and the first
day of spring
they give this store away you get
whatever the [ __ ] you want free water
ice
falling is finally back up with a
[ __ ] pickup truck
we've got our own cooler dry ice in the
back seat
uh we don't even do that we're not we're
not garbage like that
the foley's don't go for the free [ __ ]
now i'm not saying my mom doesn't have a
bunch of [ __ ]
bed backed and beyond 20 big coupons you
can't avoid those things if you wake up
they're under your pillow
they get those things they get those
[ __ ] coupons everywhere how is that
place still in business i think they're
going out of business
yeah it's 20 off if you need it
what do you give you the store yeah but
no we don't i don't [ __ ] with anything
that's a tough one i'll do a dollar dog
night i'm not saying that
that's a deal that's not a freebie yeah
you know big hats but a freebie there's
just something so
innately trashy about like standing in
line to get your
small slurpee then you get there like oh
we're all out of the coke you got to
have [ __ ] fan that you're like what
are we
no i want the goods i'll come in
tomorrow and buy a proper thing of what
i want
we the foleys don't wait in line for
anything like that
we just don't we don't camp after
tickets skinner tickets
a couple of meatloaf tickets huh that's
fleetwood who's buying huh
yeah we don't we don't [ __ ] with that
yeah um
yeah that's good though man um i'll take
a free dessert at the end of the meal
though
really what do you mean free dessert
what do you mean free dessert what's on
the house
i love that that's when you know you're
oh it's a little different yeah
dessert is on yeah have you ever lied to
say it's your birthday to get a free one
no
we don't do that [ __ ] either there's no
singing happy birthday happy happy
birthday had to
hit the [ __ ] some [ __ ] meth head
get the [ __ ] out of here all skeeved up
um this is a big one it goes back to the
milk and i love how all the listeners
spill milk milk it's [ __ ]
home run funny um which is more garbage
milk with dinner or soda with breakfast
oh man which i have done not too
long ago soda and an omelette it just
doesn't
[ __ ] work man it's real it's like
it's like mixing two worlds stop looking
at yourself
whatever this guy likes this look on
camera
stop tanking i i need to look at one
winner keep eye contact
stop why do you got to do that be weird
do you have you ever had soda with
breakfast
yeah absolutely when was the last time
you had soda with breakfast
last week that was
got nasty sniper it was a breakfast
sandwich
from did you make it no what am i a
[ __ ]
diner no what's make a breakfast
sandwich man that's my mom's [ __ ] you
know what's great dude
being all hungover going to mickey d's
and getting a [ __ ]
a screaming cold fountain coke the
perfect amount of bubbles they put in
they got scientists back there dropping
in one too many bubbles
oh it's great speaking of mcdonald's i
did something real trashy last week i
got
two two breakfast sandwiches when i did
uh when i did r.a.p
uh dylan last week i came in
um i got a mcgriddle and a sausage
mcmuffin biscuit
oh watch him watch when you're watching
your intake i see
yikes but i only got through half of the
sausage biscuit and then when i got out
of rap
it was in the bag in the back seat and i
ate it cold on the way home
that just made my blood run cold did i
swear to god i got a chill down my spine
picture you
[ __ ] playing bumper cars down [ __ ]
sixth avenue
reaching back for a cold sammy to shove
down your [ __ ] belly love eating and
driving i don't know what it is love
eating and doing anything
what are we talking about i love eating
and eating eating and sleeping eating
and farts i love
eating and driving man i love eating on
the move i don't know why
you know i'm a go-getter
call me charlie hustle i like to [ __ ]
keep it like [ __ ]
foley vaynerchuk over here i'm moving
daddy oh
soda with breakfast i'll do it i was
doing it
a lot in the quarantine a coke zero
and like you know something going on uh
what if
you what if you're in a diner at night
and you're getting breakfast that's
different because sodium
i do yeah i'll get i know you're gonna
die he needs two too he gets that first
one in like an appetizer
yeah first one just to take the edge off
clear my head let me tell you something
uh
just a heads up to all the [ __ ]
waiters and [ __ ] diners out there
when things get back to normal
kippy likes his [ __ ] second refill
quickly if he's gonna look around for
you it's coming off the top
yeah well what the [ __ ] down to 15 real
quick 15 that's where you start
um when you drop because i'm going to
have one before the food i'm going to
you're going to drop one i'm going to
finish it the food's gonna come and i'll
if you don't ask go another diet coke i
don't i need to eat and drink like we
talked about in sean patton episode
sipping bites i'm a bite and sip kind of
guy i'm trash i don't care what it is
it's a soft pretzel or a slice of
[ __ ] pizza and a cold
i like when i have the food like a
little you can see my little lip
on the rim of that you gotta go the
extra [ __ ] disgusting yard
every time every time you do a little
tuna fish
uh but soda with breakfast is [ __ ]
trash psychopath stuff
for sure um but i i am guilty as charge
that was from sam appreciate it sam
thank you sammy
um have you ever lived in a household
with more pets than people and that's
from bargoils
jesus christ no but i've been high
school people would have like i remember
the girl
like my buddy's mom was breeding ugh
hamsters what that's like corny level
[ __ ]
who pretends there's one living with the
yak woman
dude times must have been tough and they
didn't have a professional setup there
was no
it was just a couple of a couple of
[ __ ] boxes
the thunderdome it was like hedonism for
[ __ ]
what the smell
and you can never clean up all the chips
so there's pea chips floating around
she'd have a whole [ __ ] she had like
three or four boxes of them
i don't know who they were wait is there
money in that what's going on
merchandise what's it go for a nickel
i mean there can't there can't be a big
profit margin on [ __ ] breeding them i
guess in [ __ ] bluebell in the 90s
there was
geez and the things were wide open back
before the mob got involved
thanks a lot bin laden for the democrats
regulating everything
big business coming in oh hold on
more animals than people i remember this
girl would be like we have 37
like they were like the [ __ ] 37 what
dogs we have 16
cats we have this like it was like
[ __ ] ace ventura when he goes
when he opens up his door high school
girlfriend no the penguin slides out of
the
freezer and [ __ ] and she was like i
remember going you would go and she'd
like to put all the dogs in the backyard
or there was chickens and [ __ ] it was
[ __ ] wild
more than two dogs is trash yeah because
you can't stay on top
unless you've got a live-in maid you
can't stay on top of the hair
i.e or the poop or the piss if you got
more than
yeah two dogs is the cut off yeah
yeah cats is two two but you can't
no more than three animals total yeah
you can't do two cats and two dogs
depends on the house is run i wouldn't
marry somebody i wouldn't marry or date
somebody that had that many dogs
really no that's crazy huh got
aristocrat
i'm in the move i'm in the i'm in the
market for a puppy if any of you know
any breeders by the way are you yeah we
were gonna look in a hamster
rock bottom prices let me wet my beak
on the hamster i'll give it to you i'll
give it to you a cost plus five
only five points on a hamster my buddy
just picked just got a rescue but he got
it from
alabama hamster
this one comes from an abused family
they were fighting them actually
cigarette butts put out on them no it
was a dog that he got from alabama and
they drove it up
and we had to meet them at a mall you
were there
i went i went with you to pick it up it
was during the pandemic i had nothing to
do it was a [ __ ]
you know who's that art who's that hard
up for a rescue
i guess that's the only place they could
get one there was nothing in philly
you're telling me there was no dog
between philly and alabama well i'm sure
you know
i'm sure you didn't want a [ __ ] pity
i'm supposed to sit here as a [ __ ]
educated adult who went to college
temple 2.5 uh gpa
and believe that there wasn't a possible
dog for them to get between here in
alabama listen that's neither here nor
there this is where they got the dog
from they got it shipped up from alabama
came up in a van and alabama she was
wearing hammers
um jesus christ okay
this one is from aaron how quickly could
you get your hands on prescription
painkillers right now
you got a minute what's up well i can
say this
from my experience which i've tried now
i thought it would be easy
because i remember when i was you know i
was partaking in some you know
doctor feel good over here
i like to ride the lightning a little
bit when we were back in philly
and i remember a little too close to the
sun i remember i kind of put the feelers
out there now i don't know if the family
was playing defense on me if they knew
what i was up to
the family well she's saying how could
you get that's where you start you start
somebody somebody's got a script an aunt
an uncle somebody that's sick or
something
that's where you start i thought that's
what the question is where i go
oh i can make a phone call we'll have
some school buses on the way
oh really yeah why are you still like
would you like to still have i still
have some friends that are into
nefarious activities when we go to like
thanksgiving or christmas i
you know oh my back's killing me oh
really you're playing the seed
i just have like tylenol you get
anything stronger it's killing me
i would do that i always come up empty
except for once it worked out christmas
eve
whew dumbbell didn't see it coming on
screwballs
how quickly yeah i couple of calls
it depends what city i'm in here less
but for sure i mean
hear more i think i think here i can get
anything within an hour
yeah all of my i wanted to all of my
dirt bags not that i would
all of my dirt pack friends are still in
there right after i what i the biggest
accomplishment for me was i would have
to reach out to somebody to get the
number
i don't have any numbers anymore yeah
that's yeah yeah of course but that's
two phone calls two texts
you had two phone calls hey do you still
have charlie's number still have jojo's
number whatever the [ __ ]
not to do their real name you cut this
tape can you beat that
for legal purposes um
this is from austin have you ever been
to an all-day music festival sponsored
by a radio station
that is guard but jingle balls or
whatever
yeah jingle ball yeah i was we we
participated in one we did stand-up
comedy at music fest in allentown
yeah that's different though um i did i
went to like
1029 mgk's what's the one in delaware
there's one in delaware in the summer
firefly
but that's a music that's a proper music
festival that's not like a freebie of
like
i went to one at the piazza in philly
for like wmg k's
john de bella wmg classic rock maybe not
b101 might have been b101 there you go
um no but it was like newer bands
spin cities or somebody might i don't
know so we went and it was like i'm
sitting there with a bunch of [ __ ]
mouth breathers with like the big
[ __ ] you know
margaritas and so i'm like what the [ __ ]
am i doing i hate those [ __ ] those
those yards oh and then like those are
garbage you keep it for a couple of
years
yeah the house ends up with change in it
that's [ __ ] trash and you're always
like it's never like i want i want it to
be like a [ __ ] comedy show where you
go out
a band comes on does 15 minutes gets off
and hey keep it going for the [ __ ]
smiths or the johnsons and then
you know but there's like they got a
breakdown set up there's like 45 minutes
between each act you're sitting there
like a [ __ ] jerk off my buzz is
wearing off
[ __ ] like an [ __ ] not a big music
festival guy
not a big concert guy it was the last
concert you went through that bought a
ticket like a proper concert
um i would have to say it was elton john
billy joel at the continental center
over there in jersey
saw it with my ex-girl and we had broken
up
we'd broken up but she had bought me the
tickets for my birthday like trash
a couple months later she had the
tickets too she couldn't ice me but
she's a good kid
she reached out she was like haiti you
still want to go she was looking for a
little
she wasn't because that was my whole
plan you got a limo and stuff
no we took a bus there and back yeah
what and i was like trying to you took a
bus with your ex to go to a [ __ ]
concert yeah and i was trying to
convince her on the way back to [ __ ]
like a greyhound or like a city bus like
uh no like a new jersey transit bus
oh dude those things that was like
downtown beirut those
i was a young kid i didn't have any cash
all right what are you now but
i'm holding i'm an old man i got no keys
i would take an uber now but i was
[ __ ] putting the full core press
to try to get back to her house you guys
were right next to the bathroom in the
back
and uh i think she pretended to be
asleep most of the way home
do you blame her i was like i would have
pretended to be dead
little [ __ ] i would have jumped out
that fire escape
[ __ ] that was the last concert [ __ ]
fat no tooth guy making a move on i was
talking on a new jersey transit
i wanted her back so bad baby come back
she crushed me
for years she crushed me it seems like
you're over it
[Laughter]
you i roll for the audio listener um
this is a big one this is from dick talk
i don't know if that's a government
name growing up what liquid did you use
to make hot chocolate
milk or water that's not even an option
you
psycho what oh to make hot chocolate i'm
thinking chocolate
if you're making chocolate milk with
water [ __ ]
dm me all vemo you're making a homemade
i'll venmo you a couple of beans
uh we were we were water people because
i don't think we knew any better
it wasn't until like i was an adult
where i realized holy [ __ ]
you can use milk so much creamier and
then we would do it in the pan
in the pan like a saucepan like a like a
pot pour the milk
get it boiling put the powder in there
to stir it up talk about home on the
range what are you talking about
what you put in the microwave like an
animal or boil oh
i i don't know we were definitely a
water family until my stepmom came
around in the mid 90s and she introduced
us to ovaltine chocolate milk
[ __ ] blew my hair back dude that and
a couple of [ __ ]
ginger snaps good night man those ginger
snaps they're we're in ginger snap
season i know
prime ginger snapsees if you go to my
mom's house she's got a couple left over
from last season too
man those things the way they melt
inside the ah there's a point
there's a two second period where you
got to get those things out before they
[ __ ] liquid yeah they don't have a
shelf life no
you got to get them get them in get it
out get them down i know
but dude where you was like swiss miss
right that was the brand yeah we used
swiss man did you do marshmallows or no
no marshmallows what am i a [ __ ]
[ __ ] of course
marshmallows the ones that came in the
swiss miss packet
yeah i used to eat them i would just
take a spoon
right off the top i don't know what they
were but they weren't they were like
lucky charms uh
marshmallows lucky charms you really hit
your [ __ ] irish brogue on charms
they were lucky chairs yeah we were one
of those families that put [ __ ] extra
marshmallows in the thing
yeah a regular marshmallow doesn't work
in there yeah they do
not the big ones but the [ __ ] little
guys for sure no you know my
my girlfriend in high school her mom
would make the hot chocolate with with
milk
okay and put [ __ ] the marshmallows in
and then take a [ __ ]
torch and and cook the marshmallows
french what's going on damn yeah
that's what they did nice she got the
welder's mask on flips it down
like she's in running man that's a deep
cut
isn't that running man with arnold
schwarzenegger yeah i don't remember the
well there was like a torch guy like a
flame flower guy i don't know
whatever just laugh at it and move on
will you this can't all be home runs our
second episode of the day
we were water people yeah for sure yeah
we weren't wasting milk on [ __ ] hot
chocolate that was for dinner
there was none for none left over for
dessert both i've always got a beer
helmet on with two
two things of milk you ever do this
for a while for some reason uh the
pre-made chocolate milk was was big in
our house we always had a gallon like a
huge [ __ ] gallon of that in the
fridge
my my sisters do my sister my brother
and sister do that for their kids and i
got the big like turkey hill or like
the local-ish chocolate milk farm but
but they would heat that up and make
chocolate milk
oh really yeah what's that turn into
it seems like you're reducing it down to
making a [ __ ] creme brulee or
something like a pudding yeah were you a
pudding family
no absolutely not what like the pudding
snacks you weren't with those guys
no we used to make it homemade you have
to wait till like the next day it was
brutal
i remember one time i was [ __ ]
[ __ ] making dessert the night before
the babysitter tried to make us make our
own ice cream i was like
i don't know if you've checked the
garage freezer recently but there's a
[ __ ] gallon of briars in there
and i don't like the pink [ __ ] either
all right so keep it on the left side of
the road will ya
hey honey my mom didn't leave a 20 for
treats so you could [ __ ] show us how
they lived in the 80s
dominoes yeah and get the briars out
with the [ __ ] hershey's take me on a
walk to dairy queen or you followed i'll
say you grabbed me
yeah [ __ ] that i remember put it in like
a coffee can with ice and we were like
rolling it back and forth
you got to keep it moving the only thing
acceptable to make at home
is cookies okay brownies any bit any
bait's good yeah and the rice krispie
treat yeah yeah
that's it make your own ice cream when
does that stop then you're making your
own sour cream like when the
[ __ ] is [ __ ] dilling my own pickles
and [ __ ]
although my brother did his own pickles
this summer they were awesome oh good
for him
half sours shout out to the boon
[Laughter]
i tell you what fat kid's always funny
one man
everybody loves those drops not on the
youtube comments
forget about it that kid's [ __ ]
that's a that's a left left right combo
one two three punch right there um
is it garbage this is from teapot uh
is it more garbage to shower at night
before bed or to shower in the morning
before work or school
this is a great one this is fantastic
and there is a right answer
no there's not yes there is well there's
a 100 right answer
we were always uh a sh
after you got done your [ __ ] paper
route
we were always a shower before bed
and when i was growing up what age give
me an age on that all the way through
high school okay yeah but see the
problem was your hair was all [ __ ] up
in the morning
oh yeah it looks like you brush it with
firecrackers
and i this is before we knew what like
conditioner was
and like in the winter remember how like
stuff using sos pads and [ __ ] how
staticky your hair would be
especially if you put a stocking hat on
you put that winter hat on you take that
off you're [ __ ]
you're like a thing of wintergreen
sparkling everywhere
um but i'll say this you sleep better
when you take a nice shower at night of
course
before you go to bed but i think to be
the cleanest
yeah you wake up and take a shower yeah
yeah yeah it's fine if you want to take
one to go
before bed by all means i did it last
night
it took a little tubby time okay tubby
time for the for the old gibster right
a little long weekend let the hair down
a little bit play with a violin a little
bit of my we do you know what you know
what's [ __ ] class
my girl just did she hung
fresh eucalyptus in the shower oh yeah
patty's been doing that forever she's
here
same thing vick's vapor rub yeah you put
a little vicks vaporub in the bottom of
the shower
that's way different than fresh
eucalyptus okay i'll tell you that much
it's like showering in the [ __ ] rain
forest over at my place meanwhile you're
in [ __ ] aisle three of cvs
open up the pores it's just nice it
loosens the shoulders a bit even if it's
mental but
if you shower at night that's fine it
[ __ ] your hair up you got it [ __ ]
you gotta take a q even if it's a quick
run bot
you're not dirty but you're not fresh no
that's the thing
you're not dirty 100 you shower you sit
on the couch
have a little midnight snack maybe you
take you off to bed
that's fine you're not dirty you wake up
you gotta [ __ ] you gotta rinse off
i feel like it's different for the
ladies the ladies can get away with the
shower the night before
but guys we're just you know we're more
distant you're going
yeah you know you gotta [ __ ] you gotta
get in
and if not you got soot on you and oil
and stuff you
[ __ ] microbes you know you spanked it
the night before when you got into this
you got into the sheets yeah yeah i did
what check please
[Laughter]
yeah for sure you got a shower in the
morning that's [ __ ] hands down
great question though yeah that was from
yeah it was from teapot
um did your parents own a vehicle this
is from jason did your parents own a
vehicle that didn't run
or did your parents regularly experience
car trouble
say that one more time i apologize did
your parent this is from jason did your
parents own a vehicle that didn't run
or did your parents regularly experience
car trouble did you ever have like a
lemon
or you just couldn't get it right only
once they had a lemon my parents were
always great on that they were big lease
people
so if we had a problem you just take it
right back to the dealership
usually under warranty uh if not your
fudge a little paperwork you know what i
mean is it a four is it an eight who
knows they only mistake my parents my
car wise my parents were always on
[ __ ] point
always 80s we had a [ __ ] pontiac that
was [ __ ] tight
pontiac what uh like i don't know
whatever it was firebird
white jeans on ah no they were always on
point pontiac we went from pontiac to
nissan maximus for about
10 years oh [ __ ] what are you in the
russian mob nissan maxima
they were hot in the early 90s late 80s
early 90s what color was it
they varied navy blue is usually a
couple different colors
there's a red in the front maybe blues
oh that's real trashy if that's that's
on here somewhere yeah
multiple colored cards wow get the [ __ ]
out of here
i had worse so my first car was uh
chevy lumina 1200 beans shout out to my
stepdad 1200 bucks chevy lumina
and i talked to a guy in the car biz
like owns dealerships and what happened
was so i think it was a 96
96 chevy to cut prices or just do
something
they used galvanize their own galvani i
think they use galvanized steel
for the car instead of ungalvanizing
galvanized
paint doesn't stick to okay but they
didn't i got no i don't know i get
somehow slipped through the cracks
they knew so
especially after a couple of years a
little wear and tear
the paint would [ __ ] yeah those
luminous dude it would strip off
like you could just and like all my
friends would get all high and drunk
like just pull
chips off dude so mine was like it
looked like started it looked like snow
camo
like the doors would just be like
there'd be no paint on the doors or no
paint on the trunk or no paint on the
hood
mine was all in it i was like spray
painting and stuff at a time
using like you're supposed to be called
touch-up pain i was using like nine cans
of that [ __ ] nail polish yeah taping off
the [ __ ] taping off the [ __ ] uh oh
really
yeah i was like i was like double it was
like mako in my driveway for a little
bit
i've painted a lot of [ __ ] in my day
i've never used painters tape once
yeah eyeball it how big get what you get
if i might do the first run but then
like you know
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that [ __ ] always sucked
that was the worst part of it taping
everything up first get the [ __ ] out of
here
it's broad ain't gonna know i know i'll
be long gone by the time she sees it
that one i was going to i was going to
ireland in college and i needed my mom's
like i'll give you 200 bucks if you
paint the bathroom or whatever so i'm
like all right
[ __ ] spray paint yeah dumbbell didn't
see us coming
[ __ ] i wasn't in the [ __ ] better
business brewer i'll tell you that much
this is before [ __ ] yelp or amanda's
choice over the angie's list
because dude i believe i look like i had
parkinson's when i was [ __ ] trimming
out the [ __ ]
there was it was like the mirror i was
like an olive green i sure
i forget but dude it was all over this
the ceiling was supposed to be white
but it [ __ ] it looked like i was
[ __ ] throwing m80s in that place dude
there was paint
everywhere anytime i was asked to do
some [ __ ] like that i
half-assed everything i know get the
[ __ ] out of here
yeah clippings on the lawn [ __ ] did i
remember
right in the leaves you couldn't even
tell [ __ ] about it the whole time
i know i have to i grew up cutting the
grass and we had a [ __ ] john deere
from like
i'm not even [ __ ] like 1972. this
thing was like big metal no plastic
sit down sit down wow big boy like
[ __ ]
heavy duty somebody new i love those
residential
sit-down mowers they're one of my
favorite things of all time but this was
like
kind of between like this was before
things got small
and technology this was like a [ __ ]
big green
metal [ __ ] hunk of steel didn't have
the like the long front
and the tires on the side the big tires
in the back bigger tires in the back
little tiny ones in the front yeah i
burned myself on one of those real bad
i grabbed the muffler as a little kid
jesus christ
i like ran up to my dad while i was
cutting the grass and i grabbed onto it
campo fanique that's when i got
introduced to that you know what campo
panique
is that english campo panic was like a
like a
disinfectant or pain reliever solar cane
no we didn't have solar cane money did
it have solar cane money bad work for
the navy what are you talking about
solar king [ __ ] out of here you got camp
opening and you got iodine that was it
was what is this a [ __ ] civil war
hospital iodine
who's putting iodine on it we used to
put my mom used to put iodine onto
everything
any time we had a cut or something like
eggs in the morning
so numb you up a little bit rub a little
in your gums
like you're gonna brush you might enough
time to brush my teeth i got iodine in a
glove box
it's stung like a [ __ ] we were
big
uh dark balls for sure
uh like alka rabbit like you know or
like hydrocortisone or whatever not
cortisone the hydro
codeine not hydrogen peroxide peroxide
you get to see it working
bubbles buddy hit something with some
bubbles
i love that i love the sting yeah i
remember we would like do it and like
i'd like watch if my brother had
something we'd do it to him and like
because you'd want to see the bubbles
and then if they were complaining and
there was no real bubbles you're like
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
we used to do that bubbles dude i feel
like there was a lot of times where me
and my brother
if one of us were like injured or
something like that like i remember
watching my mom
scrape blackheads out of my brother's
ear
what in the [ __ ] what is he a golden
retriever
check please scraping blackheads out of
his ear yeah with a with a
pair of tweezers that she bent up to get
the nice scrape and she would scrape
them out of there
it was before those suction things i
used to always watch each other get that
done i don't know why any anything like
that we'd watch it you didn't have cable
[Laughter]
and what sound tonight broken femur
iodine pretty quick this guy
[Music]
well that's garbage
um all right let's see here
this is from cg did anyone ever forget
to pick you up at school or anywhere
let me tell you ever been forgotten yeah
i've been forgotten a lot
i don't think i've ever been proper
forgotten but i've definitely been
de-prioritized
i've definitely been put at the bottom
of the list in priorities for my dad
because he showed up with a couple of
[ __ ] rolling rocks and nicole
my mom lost me in a kmart when i was
probably
i might have been pre-kindergarten
because i didn't know what was going on
and hiding in the circle rack of jackets
no remember that that was a guy oh
yeah that was fun that's when you were
in control but i think this broad just
left me in an
aisle yeah and forgot that i was there
and like walked around the corner and i
didn't know
i didn't know whether to [ __ ] or go
blind i was just wandering around
screaming and this is the 80s everyone
mind their own business back then nobody
was [ __ ]
mom's the word
keep it moving ah
and i just kept wandering around and
wandering around it felt like days
probably like 10 minutes but i'm a
little fat kid you know probably all
jacked up on an icy
wandering around and luckily just by
coincidence my aunt lorraine
just working just happened she might
have worked there
just happened to be in the store and she
found me that's why i always loved my
aunt lorraine
not to mention she makes nut roll at
christmas fantastic
that's not the only time she makes it
that was the first time
second time when we moved from
wilkes-barre down to philly
okay down to the burbs of philly i told
you we lived in town line apartment
town line townhouse community which was
like a [ __ ] maze when you you know
when you didn't know it
everything looks the same yeah every i
didn't know where the f i didn't know my
[ __ ] address did like
when did you know what your address was
i don't i mean college
i didn't [ __ ] know where the [ __ ] i
lived sure and
my brother went to like the middle
school and i was going to the elementary
school
and i guess she picked up my brother at
the bus stop
and then or had to pick my brother up
from school something
anyway i know we had a [ __ ] plan she
was going to meet me in the car
at the [ __ ] bus stop and i get off
and there's no car
yikes yeah it's the fall it's getting
dark
i don't know the [ __ ] neighborhood so
there i am again just wandering around
[ __ ]
screaming people are probably eating
dinner some fat kid walking by
staring through the window
and eventually i mean this was a level
of panic
that has crea built insecurity in me
to this day i didn't think any i was
never gonna
really you seem like a cool guy i didn't
think i was ever gonna be [ __ ] found
i just happened to stumble into the
[ __ ] uh the rental office
and i just walked away what's the price
of a two bedroom in this dump
you guys give military discounts my old
man i don't know where he is but he
served
and i walked in
[ __ ] just freaking out i think they
kicked me out of the rental office
because i was
jamming up the works that guy was ready
to get guys ready to close somebody on a
[ __ ]
on a studio meanwhile a little fat kid
comes in with a tie-dyed shirt
all of a sudden he's got these he's
gonna take a walk i'm working here
hey kid here's a dollar snack machine's
done a haul get the [ __ ] out of my face
you got kids what the [ __ ] hey go play
in those bushes fatty
and then uh i got a whale on the line
over here because
i don't remember them taking me to my
house
i remember leaving there like yeah
walking in and then walking out
and now like my book bag's sliding off
my back
my coats have opened ah it's like night
of the living dead for lost little fat
boys
i'm a little fat boy and then i remember
[ __ ]
i somehow made it back to the bus stop
but she was like pulling up flicking a
marble laid out though
yeah probably putting her underwear back
on
oh mom's
and i remember my brother laughing at my
[ __ ] face about it
for so long dude i remember one time we
were playing shout out that we were
tapestry we were playing tap we were
playing
uh it's the name of the neighborhood
tapas it's like a townhouse community
but they were they had court so we went
there to play somebody lived in the
neighborhood we went there to play
roller hockey i was probably like
i couldn't drive 14 like i was yeah
probably 14 maybe
13 12 12 to 14. and i'm in there same
thing as
spring so it didn't get like didn't stay
dark out that long right
and we're playing with like 10 kids
didn't stay light out that's what i mean
yeah sorry it got dark it was still
getting dark early
yeah you know seven o'clock or whatever
that's when it got frightening when you
were a kid
man that's sun why is everything so
scary at night even now
sometimes i'll just pee my pants so i
don't have to get up i hate driving down
a [ __ ] empty road at night
oh dude i got a game plan for sure
something comes out
waiting for the slender man to get me
knock on wood um
but uh hold on
pin in that story we were i just went up
the uh cat skills not too long ago over
a couple of you know a month or two ago
not at night shout out to flip
and it's in the morning so it's like
still weird but it's like when you're
thinking you're like oh this is kind of
like the beginning of a movie two
couples go
they're staying in the woods and you're
like pick it like
so we get in the morning we're like
driving girls doing both the guys
you were there so we're driving the
window and you're like in this country
road so it's like a house every now and
then or whatever it's all windy
you know and uh there's this old man
like deranged you're looking in his eyes
and he ain't there i don't know where he
is
where was he he's staying in the middle
of the road shut the [ __ ] up dude
[ __ ] dirty like real dirty jeans what
not like dirt like mud like he's just
had them on for 20 years
ran him right over so my buddy flip is
driving i'm in the back seat
he's in the middle of the like a country
road country road and he's got a little
white fluffy dog and the dog's now like
we can't see the dog because he's up on
the car so the guy's coming to the heart
like
he's telling us to get the [ __ ] out of
here like but he doesn't know where he
is or who he's talking to he's yelling
at somebody in another decade
in his life oh my god
and i'm dude i'm yelling flip's going
hey man you got to get out of the way
and i'm like [ __ ] mulch him dude
i'm like or put it in reverse [ __ ]
kate to like [ __ ] u-turn let's go
kill the headlights and [ __ ] throw it
in reverse
i'm like put it i'm like dude [ __ ]
reverse like now i'm pat and when i go
it's [ __ ]
i'm like dude i'm full fighter flight
play 2020 i'm like i'll [ __ ] mold and
then he's going i
don't i don't want to run over the dog
i'm going [ __ ] the dog
this this we got a zombie he's going to
steal our souls
[ __ ] stick and move what are we doing
it's going to turn us into stone so
finally it just took me screaming
go so we backed up and then we were able
to like [ __ ] zip around
but dude [ __ ] dead man [ __ ]
walking right down then we [ __ ] that
dude we're like two miles away
[ __ ] to exactly i'm like this is how it
starts i'm like
later that night i'm like next thing you
know you turn around he's in the back
seat yeah
the dog's driving the [ __ ] we get to we
get to the like the turkey or whatever
like the little convenience store and
we're like
is there something is it like a crazy
guy that walks around here guy slowly
turns around that guy's been dead for 37
years
um do you have a little white dog with
him yeah but i [ __ ] talk
so but my we're playing hockey like 12
13 years old whatever
and everybody gets picked up right like
mrs [ __ ] whoever
comes and gets billy and steve hey kev
do you need a ride now am i my dad's
coming [ __ ] you know then mrs johnson
comes and gets [ __ ]
and then finally it's like one other
person and me and then like you know
liam's mom comes and it's just
i'm like you grew up with a liam yeah
they're like oh do you see
do you need a ride i'm like no no no my
dad's coming he said 5 15.
it's now 6 30 man yeah well he liked him
he's got three schlitzer's
uh he liked the he liked the michelobs
he wasn't a beer guy he was a michelin
guy
i don't drink beer just make a little is
it beer or michelob
uh and plus he has like foil on the
bottle oh yeah
those 80s guys thought they were real
classy with those things get a low in
brown
give me a jinger and zip it okay yeah
you're in some mozz sticks
so he [ __ ] uh he i'm talking now it's
getting dark
and i'm like that's the panic start
setting you like am i going to be here
forever i'm like
i'm four miles from my house i got
rollerblades i don't know what i gotta
cross a main road what the [ __ ] going
on here no cell phones i'm just waiting
so i'm like oh maybe if i skate if i
like i think i might just slide my
roller blades on there maybe i took them
off in case i had to make a [ __ ] move
be able to get out of all terrain you
know what i mean can't be handed up
trying to rub through the door
zipping around like casey jones like a
jerk off
can't be running through the woods in a
set of powers
come on man tripping over the break
little fat kid with a bowl cut come on
mister don't kill me
my dad's on his way uh he shows up dude
it's like now it's like dark
like and i'm like maybe you're so naive
or whatever like maybe if i skate i'll
like walk to the front of the by the
time i get to the front of the thing
i'll be pulling in and i'll
i sat there like a [ __ ] jerk off till
like 10
30. are you crying i don't i don't think
i was that far from it but i wasn't
finally gets in like nothing i'm like
where the [ __ ] were you got tied up with
the thing with the guy
meanwhile there's like [ __ ] michelobs
rolling around in the back seat
he played it fast and loose with the
open containers i'll tell you that much
is tough no bueno
that was a great question great question
that was from cg
uh this is from james who was an old
center city comedy james
supporter from way back in the day thank
you james um
do you this is different because we we
live in the city so it's a little bit
with the air conditioning do you adjust
the thermostat when you leave for the
day
so when you come back or do you just
like let it the heat on all day
or the yeah we got window units in the
city so we crank them but now
the new air conditioner we have has some
kind of bluetooth
remote thing my girlfriend can turn it
on when we're close to we're like 20
minutes out like
say we're down at my parents for the
weekend i got a vibrator like that
hey honey i'm three stops away
start the appetizers i'll be home for
dinner
uh but no like we're coming over the gw
bridge zip it on yeah
it's [ __ ] nice it's a little
different dude we're my we got the one
my mother was a nazi about that oh yeah
that's that's the thing it's so insane
now now my parents my parents today will
sit on the couch
in winter jackets like they're out of
the winter like they're at an eagles
game
and they're saying they're sitting on
like a [ __ ] 3 000
sofa wearing [ __ ] winter jackets i'm
like crank the heat up a little bit it's
nine bucks here's a 20.
i'm here for the weekend it's crazy i
just don't get it we weren't allowed to
[ __ ] if we even looked at the thermostat
as a kid
we got a [ __ ] hand in the back of the
head it used to be like the turn one
then we got the digital one and now that
the big thing with us is run program you
gotta run program
if you're leaving if you leave him press
run program it'll take it up to 72 or
whatever you know what i mean like it's
not going to full bl
i'm like lame that's garbage [ __ ] you
got a couple of bucks
i paid the time take it out of my take
it out of the will what are we doing i
work too damn hard
to get out of my allowance to be [ __ ]
give me one slice of bread on the
sandwiches
i'm trying to do keto anyway
[Laughter]
i love a roll-up somebody posted a
picture in the uh
uh facebook uh fan page roll it was a
pickle in the center with cream cheese
and ham
that's also shout out to if you're on
uh there's very active facebook groups
reddit
and now discord which i don't really
know a whole bunch about but there's
three active things so if you're on
those you can check them out people
thank you guys we appreciate the love
and all that [ __ ] it's great um
all right let's see um this what
this is from jay adrian what home
remedies did your mom use when you were
sick
this is a big one for some reason for us
ginger ale was like the [ __ ]
cure-all ginger ale my mom did [ __ ]
nothing dude that
and that and some toast oh yeah or
sprite
my mom i'm like dude we were i'm like
[Laughter]
should have said travis scott god damn i
tell you what fat kid's always funny one
man
two same drops in the same show it's
gonna have to talk to my attorney
um sprite sprite it was like if you were
i don't know that is it was the 90s dude
sprite was a health drink root beer
no it was sprite and toast it was a
clear liquids was the thing
anything clear i didn't do [ __ ] yeah you
know my mom got into
i think ketamine
a little bit of seroquel stop the
screaming
um was cryptic you know what krypnik is
no but it does not sound classy
it's some kind of polish liqueur like
lemon ginger something liqueur
and she would give us a little bit of
that in a cup of tea
and when you're like [ __ ] 12 that's
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] lights out yeah
what we used to do for toothaches was
the jack daniels yeah
little [ __ ] you up little jack daniels
on the [ __ ] num rubbing nummies with
jd
wonder why i got such a [ __ ] problem
taste for the booze yeah
yeah that [ __ ] would [ __ ] we we would do
that over like let's go get some [ __ ]
ambisol
what do you give me [ __ ] evan
williams for i know i think it's some
at some point in the 90s
we obviously there was a little i mean
like you know it was [ __ ]
they would rub it on your gums when you
were teething too they'd rub a little
little but like we would do [ __ ] to like
cut three bucks
you know what i mean like yeah we're not
gonna do this do this i'm like what like
looking back i'm like what the [ __ ] were
we saving the pennies for
you know what i mean [ __ ] just go buy
some ambisol or some [ __ ] aura gel or
whatever
like we're all you know like taking oh i
think whoever's got a thing
what are we doing using old neosporin i
remember recycling
antibiotics like oh well uh so-and-so
still has some antibiotics that they
didn't take i'll get you them
sure i think someone's got a half a
z-pack they almost killed me one time
with that because they got me
uh antibiotics from somebody else and i
was allergic to whatever the antibiotics
were
and i remember distinctly because i felt
like i had glass in my stomach
and it was taco night ate a cup it was
taco night and i remember being so
pissed off because i couldn't have the
tacos
see your lots changed [ __ ] sucks mom
it's probably why they gave it to me so
i'd stay away save a couple bucks on the
ground beef yeah
um you know what i used to [ __ ] love
uh dimetapp
remember that no what time it tap yeah
like cold stuff who are you diane keaton
what the [ __ ] is that you don't know
what documentation is a great dime
attack yeah we got robitussin like a
[ __ ] gentleman damn that was
heavy-duty stuff
i had to operate him with heavy
machinery i used to love cough medicine
when i was like
that diamond tap was [ __ ] cough
medicine get right back in here yeah one
time i drank a half a bottle of cough
medicine when i was sick and my mother
freaked the [ __ ] out drugged me to the
pharmacy got epic
drug me back home was it the 20s it
became yeah got on top of me like pinned
me down
i'm listening can we lower the lights in
here please
got on top of me like [ __ ] like you
know like blocked my arms with their
knees
and like opened my mouth and poured epic
down my throat so i would throw up
psycho good time check please this guy's
a [ __ ]
looney hello cough medicine and cough
drops i loved when i was a kid ludens
good night are they national do you
think luden's i don't know but they
there was didn't
hey there was no medicine it was just
lifesavers it was just cheering my mom
would send me to school with the thing
alluded that wouldn't even make it to
the [ __ ] bus stop
dude i'd be boofing those things
luton's on the bus yeah i was like
you're looking on [ __ ] 20
chips get your [ __ ] dick sucked in
the back
take my bags to my room
i'll be at the tables if you need to
carry my bags to homeroom will you
stretch
here's a couple of lootings treat
you know what was real nice too in high
school or even college
um a nice halls and then a bernie
really clean up the airways for the
[ __ ] ziggy
that was [ __ ] a nice cherry hauls and
then crank up more blight
yo my daddy i don't really perk up the
ears for you
uh regular halls when you were a kid
might have all been a [ __ ] shot at
cuddy stark
what i remember they would give me i
remember being like what duff my i
remember when my sister like started
performing them i'm like this broad
was she driving truck what's happening
here dude those things were [ __ ]
medicinal
i don't know why but my dad now eats
cough drops like their mints
and he'll ask you in the middle of the
summer you want a cough drop what the
[ __ ] do i want a cough drop for you
[ __ ] psycho
it's [ __ ] july 4th you're offering me
a glove truck
[ __ ] fireworks going off i don't want
a [ __ ] cough drop in the summer
dude those halls man they the [ __ ]
triangle ones
or the square ones they had a little dip
in the center first of all they'd slash
your tongue like a [ __ ]
east coast about glass oh god
holy [ __ ] so we used to choose to put
those in uh like medicinal
wrap them in cheese so you would eat
them
treat like a schnauzer [ __ ] wrapping
a piece of lunch meat
you and your brother jumping around the
kitchen [ __ ] fat idiot
no you're talking about homemade
remedies she would put a cough drop in a
thing of boiling water
they could drink that right i guess
remember oh you know what was a really
bad
holy [ __ ] chloroseptic oh
that was like that was for [ __ ] that
was like tidy bowl i don't know what
that [ __ ] was
yeah no no chloroseptic waste oh get out
of here
you had to hold me down and get that
[ __ ] at me you needed a super soaker and
a [ __ ] really good shot
to get that at the back of my throat i
just felt i might have a panic attack
thinking about that that was like half
cocaine i'm pretty sure dude it was like
[ __ ]
ethanol it was something it burned like
especially for like a six year i
remember the one time i had
and looking back it was heartburn but i
didn't know what it was as a kid oh my
god and i was doing that to take the
edge off because i had all this [ __ ]
acid coming up in my throat
[ __ ] real hottie huh
get the [ __ ] out of here with the
clothes there was a there was a bottle
of chlorocephic in my
same bottle for [ __ ] 22 years that
stuff
they put it under this put it under the
sink with the other chemicals i'm so
trashy though i can say this when i was
a kid in the winter i used to love the
cold
and flu commercials there was something
cozy about them
it almost make you wanted to be sick a
little bit methamphetamine pics
it was you know it was season
it was it was like course or whatever
the [ __ ] it was
oh holy [ __ ] i think we got time for one
more yeah
all right then let's i want to do this
then this was this is oh
a banana this is from a listener ben who
sent in this is
a piece that he sent in okay um
this is a message he sent uh and he had
sent it in the in the facebook
chat and i saw it immediately i saw the
alert i was like delete this i want to
do it on the show
and so you wouldn't see this might be
new level
wacky insane garbage i love it okay guys
i've been holding on to this one
until now i swear myself this isn't our
ben is it our friend ben
no okay i swear
i swear in my life this is all true this
is my great aunt
marge mccool sounds like a [ __ ]
winner already
my great-aunt marge is internet famous
she was my grandfather's sister
i grew up across the street from my
grandparents and aunt marge was always
around
and she always was driving a corvette or
another sports car
okay couple of bucks um i was always
told aunt marge worked an antique store
which is why she's always bringing us
awesome old stuff
well i found out by accident from my
college girlfriend that my great-aunt
marge at the ripe old age of 77 was in
fact
a stripper wow whoo must had a set of
cans on her
marge mccool more like marge mcdrew
and had been for decades i was stunned
to say the least oh she wasn't a
stripper at 74 she was in her younger
days
no she still we're only at 77. wow hence
the vet got a little bit of cage
yeah you know got to play the part can't
be showing up in a [ __ ] beat-up
lumina
aunt marge is also internet famous as
the lady who married a 31 year old
wow 77 marries a 30
one-year-old some good punani she's
probably kept in tight kegels at all
my parents were also at the daytona 500
world dale where dale earnhardt had died
at
jesus the intimidator rest in peace wow
if you don't think we were
bro if you weren't a nascar guy of
course
my step that big race guy richard petty
or dale earnhardt that was it no
jeff gordon it was it was [ __ ] it was
jeff gordon pretty boy
it was holly i hated jeff gordon for
some reason i don't even know why
meanwhile probably a good guy um
my first car which was a my grandfather
oh this my grandfather's on the local
news
was in the local newspaper for having
seen an alien spacecraft
back in the 80s my first car was a ford
ranger which i sold for a dodge neon
which i then sold for a dodge dakota
this guy's [ __ ] garbage of the year
he goes do you think i'm garbage and
then
nine and then he sends the link to aunt
marge mccool or whatever
91 year old great granny boast about her
sex life with 31 year old male
is there a picture of her yeah and she
looks 91
maybe 88.
holy [ __ ] hey you're what come on next
level
[ __ ] banana dude the grandfather's
seeing an alien spacecraft
that's awesome [ __ ] trash there when
[ __ ] dale earnhardt died
that's like that's like forrest gump
level of garbage yeah
moment in history though he went out
hard yeah
i don't know really it was like a little
[ __ ] crash what are you talking snapped
his neck
yeah but the crash was start running
your mouth hey i'm a [ __ ]
we are for sure do you like dale
earnhardt jr though
yeah well no one in our household is
junior
junior's running got poll
[Laughter]
when you got to lingo junior's running
got pulled
you're garbage and you stink yeah guys
thank you so much for listening we
appreciate it please as always
these [ __ ] questions were awesome we
got yes ten percent of them we love this
and hopefully you guys love the uh the
family episode we're gonna be doing this
once a month
uh just because the [ __ ] questions
are yeah it's just fun too it's casual
yeah it's a hang get the hang of me and
the big man get to chop it up a little
bit yeah
we love you guys guys make sure you
please rape if you subscribe on itunes
also full video available on youtube and
also
uh gas digital network you can sign up
there use promo code ayg we get to with
our beak a little bit
it's a good time uh thank you so much we
got some new shirts coming out too
yeah a little bit yeah we have a lot a
lot of new stuff coming up it'll be
great fun stuff we love you guys we'll
see you next week